ever find yourself reading all these
articles with nfts and you say i still
don't know what an nft is i don't even
know what a fungible token is
what's fungible what's crypto honestly
between me and you pat
i still don't even know what
cryptocurrency is i don't know what
blockchain is
i don't know what a spec is i don't
understand how we printed five trillion
dollars of money the last 12 months
40 of all money ever printed in us was
printed
in the last 12 months and the economy is
still going up i don't get it what the
hell is going on here
what is bit cloud what is this new thing
that's coming out with crypto for you to
be able to buy stocks and individuals
i'm all over the place pat i'm a little
bit overwhelmed
if you ever catch yourself being in a
situation
where you have no clue what's going on
and things are moving a little bit too
quickly
this is when you need to take a timeout
and not a 20-second timeout
you need to take a daytime out and sit
there and do the one
skill set that's basic nothing
complicated about it
do a ton of research you
choose these topics i want to learn
baseball cards
how is this card just sold for 5 million
dollars how is it that that card just
sold for 2 million
why would anybody buy a baseball card a
basketball card
go educate yourself because things are
moving so quickly right now
money's being made so easily right then
i'm not talking about 100 grand or a
million dollars or 10 million
millions on top of millions on top of
billions are being made right now
simply because some people took the time
to do a little bit more research than
others did
and others are just sitting there saying
i don't know i don't know
i don't know it's called research spend
a sunday
get away from everybody get a computer
out choose one of the topics you want to
research
read every single topic on nfts
on cards whatever topic that intrigues
you and then read opposing
topics on it so why nfds won't work
why nfts will go away like the complete
like the way i like to learn topics
and the reason why i love debate so much
is because that's how i learn
when we sit there and we have a meeting
with our staff and our executive team
yesterday tom and i were talking about
this and i
made this call nobody was ready for this
call just kind of set up the zoom and i
got everybody on the zoom and i knew
they were differing opinions
and i asked one question and they all
went at it right
and i sat back and i learned whether
this was the right decision to make for
a company or not
because it was debate that was discourse
so when you're doing research
don't just read one-sided research read
opposing side research
not to emotionally sway your opinion
about what it is
just to see both haters on the other
side
both critics on the other side and then
you make your decision hopefully you
know how you
know how to reason and neither person
can pull you to one direction
emotionally
after doing a ton of research yourself
you'll sit there and say
you know what this is actually not bad
and i'm interested in you know i'm going
to start off with
this much i'm going to start off with
that much i'm going to go out there and
do this area of this
i'm not touching nft i'm not touching
this but i'm going to try this
based on doing a lot of
research i've been around a lot of folks
who are very wealthy
i've been a lot a lot of folks that are
wealthy and i'm talking billionaires
and if you talk to billionaires they are
ridiculously
big on doing research on their own
you'll ask him a question let's say
we're talking having a conversation
together with them
and then all of a sudden they're not
paying attention to you anymore and
they're looking at their phones
you may be thinking they're texting
somebody they're not texting somebody
they're on the third article already
that they're reading while you're having
a conversation with them they're on the
third article
reading he said what are you looking at
i just read this article on bc that i
like what this guy said about it
here let me send it to you they send the
link airdrop and then you read out wow
that's pretty intense and then boom and
then you go back and forth
the wiring of how to figure things out
is on them
and many people out there watching this
you ought to get better
at the time out and research skill set
by the way
if you're watching this this has to do
with your own industry i'm an insurance
industry guess what i have to research
everything and anything in the insurance
industry i was having a
board called yesterday with five of the
top biggest performers and insurance and
all these ceos are there
we're talking everybody's saying how we
need to innovate product how we need to
innovate insurance how we need to
innovate this and what about this and
what about this
everyone's giving their own ideas but my
mind
is constantly thinking about researching
how
my industry could get better so this
isn't about you learning about baseball
cards
this isn't about you learning about nfts
this isn't about you learning about
spanx
interest rates or why the market is
doing so well
this is about you researching non-stop
whatever topic that matters to you both
to help you with your health
with your life with your finances with
getting clarity because the clearer you
become the better decisions you and i
are able to make and if you want a
strict specific formula on how to
research i made a video four years ago
when i was in ball harbor
how to research any topic if you've
never watched it click over here
to watch the video take care everybody
bye-bye